[موسيقى]
الآن هناك شيء دانمركي على وجه الخصوص
عندما تصل إلى إشارات المرور إذا
كانت حمراء ، فأنت تتوقف بالفعل وتنتظر
في نيويورك ليست فرصة أن أكون من خلال
تلك الأضواء قبل أن تتمكن من قول
ساندويتش
دنماركي [موسيقى]  لست خائفًا من أن تكون
فرديًا
ولكن فقط بطريقة جماعية
ودودة بشكل لذيذ ، فهي حقًا
لقاءات بكوبنهاغن كثيرة ولا يمكنني
أن أطلب شركة أفضل اليوم
من كنز وطني كبير
أنت تعني أنني أرتدي نوعًا ما  الوزن مع تقدم
العمر ،
كنت أعلم أنك ستأخذ الأمر كما لو
كنت تعرف بالضبط ما قرأته جيدًا
لقد كنت موجودًا منذ فترة طويلة ، عمري 77 عامًا ،
أنا أقدم صحفي تلفزيوني في العالم
وأعتقد أن
إرلا تيركيلسون هو ما تسميه
مؤسسة محترمة
، لقد ضحكت
كثيرًا وسمعتها الحياتية ،
إنها مراسلة تجوب العالم منذ فترة طويلة ، أغير
البلدان لأنني أعتقد أنه يجب عليك
مزج دهشتك وفضولك
والقدوم إلى مكان جديد مثل عندما
تسافر
ولكن هو  هل تبقى على اتصال مع ما
يحدث هنا ، فأنت لا تنسى
مسارك ،
ولا تنسى شمال لندن ، هل
نحن ذاهبون
إلى هنا أحضروك هنا ليكون الدنماركي
مبتذلاً ، نعم ، لكنك  بقولها
إنه لا يُطلق عليه اسم
دنماركي ، إنه يُسمى خبز venable من فيينا وفي
فيينا يُدعى kobanhagena ،
لذا ما هذا الذي يُطلق عليه
القواقع ،
هذه هي الأشياء القديمة
من طفولتي ، أعطني ثلاث
شرائح سأحصل عليها لاحقًا
[موسيقى  ]
السكر في دمي على وشك
تجاوز الحد ، شكرًا لك ، نعم ، نعم ،
لكني لا أهتم
اليوم ، فأنا أعيش أسلوب حياة الله
دون اعتذار ،
لقد كنت منفتحًا تمامًا بشأن كل
الأمور التي مررت بها  العمل ، نعم ،
في جيلي
، كانت الفكرة بأكملها هي أن المرأة
يجب أن تكون مغازلة وعدوانية جنسيًا
مثل الرجال ، فلا تقلق من
أن
الكنز الوطني قد
يتلوث ، أعتقد أن الشعب الدنماركي يتمتع
بروح الدعابة
وقد أتقنت علا المحنكة
مهارة الصحفيين أ  تحلل
وتفهم مكان ما في دقائق ، لذا
أطلب منها أن تركز سلطاتها على بلدها ،
أخبرني عن الدنمارك ،
أعتقد أنها بلد جميل للغاية وأعتقد أنها
بلد منطقي للغاية عندما تكون
هنا أنت كما لو كنت  لقد خرجت
من العالم
وذهبت إلى حديقة جميلة
للغاية مصانة جيدًا حيث كل شيء
جميل ولطيف ولكن خارج بوابة الحديقة
هناك شيء آخر يحدث
وأريد أن أذهب وألقي نظرة على ما هو
الشيء الذي تحبه أكثر في هذا الأمر
كوبنهاغن أيضًا أفكر في
عائلتي طفولتي في
عطلاتنا الصيفية ، أتذكر ذلك
عندما أتجول هنا وأتنقل تمامًا
من الاتصال إلى مكان مع العائلة
عبر التاريخ